Now that we've seen the nitration mechanism,
let's talk a little bit more about this derivative
we've made.
Nitrobenzene is less reactive than benzene.
Remember that positive charge on the nitrogen
atom?
Well that is inductively electron withdrawing
and it pulls electron density out of the ring.
Since benzene needs to use its electrons to
react in electrophilic aromatic substitution,
they are now less available due to this inductive
effect.
We call the nitro group a deactivating group,
because it deactivates the benzene ring toward
further electrophilic aromatic substitution
reactions.
We can also show how the nitro group pulls
electrons by drawing resonance structures.
We can actually use the conjugation of the
aromatic ring with the double bonded oxygen
of the nitro group to show how electrons can
be pulled out of the ring.
Now, we're just moving electrons around, so
the molecule needs to stay overall neutral,
and in this resonance form that we draw, we
end up with two positive charges and two formal
negative charges.
Now, of course, this charge separated resonance
form is not the best resonance form for nitrobenzene,
but it does contribute.
Also, it gives important insight into nitrobenzene's
reactivity.
Looking at an animation of how this resonance
occurs, notice that when a pair of electrons
moves away from any one of the carbon atoms,
we gain formal positive charge on that carbon.
We can also represent the delocalization in
nitrobenzene using a resonance hybrid.
Resonance hybrids aim to combine all of these
individual resonance forms into one structure.
This is to better represent that the overall
structure is made up of each of these resonance
forms—that one resonance form doesn't exist
at one time in a molecule—any given molecule's
actual structure is really an average of all
of its resonance structures.
When we examine our resonance forms, we see
that our oxygen atom on the right hand side
always maintains its negative charge.
So, we can draw a formal negative charge on
that oxygen atom in our resonance hybrid.
When we look at the nitrogen atom, we see
that it always stays with a formal positive
charge, so in our resonance hybrid, it will
maintain that positive charge.
Now, the oxygen atom on the left hand side
is sometimes double bonded and sometimes single
bonded.
So, here, we need to use a partial bond—a
dotted bond—to represent that double bond.
We'll also put a delta minus, since it's not
always formally negatively charged.
The bond connecting the nitrogen to the ring
is sometimes single bonded, and sometimes
double bonded.
So, we'll use our dotted double bond convention
here as well.
Now, within the ring, each carbon atom is
sometimes single bonded and sometimes double
bonded.
So, we can draw dotted bonds within the ring,
all the way around the ring, to represent
this well.
Finally, we can put delta positive charges
on three of our carbon atoms that get a formal
positive charge in one of our resonance structures.
And that generates our resonance hybrid.
We can see the significance of this analysis
when we react nitrobenzene in an electrophilic
aromatic substitution reaction.
Electrophiles are positive, so these three
carbon atoms with positive character are going
to have a repulsive interaction with an incoming
electrophile.
Therefore, the electrophile is going to bond
at one of these carbon atoms that does not
have positive character, and we can show our
electrophile bonding to just one of them in
our reaction scheme.
On a substituted benzene, we can define the
position that a new electrophile attaches
with respect to that group.
The adjacent positions are the ortho positions,
next to those are two meta positions, and
across from the group, there is one para position.
So, we can say the nitro group is a meta director.